my pleasure to welcome you to the first
of
terms to Brendan Gill lectures the
reason there are two Gil lectures this
semester can be attributed to last
January's weather when this evening
speaker joel kotkin was unable to
successfully make his way to New England
from California I don't know how hard he
really tried when he read those weather
reports later this term Kenneth Frampton
will deliver a second Gil lecture the
gill lecture series as a distinguished
history bringing important critics and
historians to our school the roster of
previous Gil lecturers includes wendy
steiner st takaya dacosta meyer david
hickey Kenneth Frampton charles jencks
Roger Khanna Hal Foster and NASA Rabat
the diversity of this roster of speakers
is as it should be given that Brendan
Gil yale college class of nineteen
thirty-six was for most of his long
career a writer with wide-ranging
interests for 50 years Gil was
associated with the new yorker magazine
contributing drama criticism and
architecture criticism among other forms
as an architecture critic he took over
the skyline column that had previously
been lewis Mumford's mr. Kotkin is the
30th lecturer in the gill series joel
Kotkin is an internationally recognized
authority on economic political and
social trends a native New Yorker he
attended the University of California at
Berkeley before establishing residents
in Los Angeles mr. cocoons first book
published in nineteen eighty-two
California Inc in California
incorporated dealt with the Golden
State's links to the emerging powers of
the Pacific Rim in 1988 he co-authored
the third century America's resurgence
in the asian asian era which has been
translated into japanese and chinese and
has also a special english edition
in the Pacific Rim mr. Kotkin is also
the author of tribes how race religion
and identity determines success in the
new global economy tracing the
connection between ethnicity and
business success tribes has been
published in Chinese Japanese Arabic and
German in two thousand he published the
new geography how the digital revolution
is reshaping the American landscape his
2006 book the city a global history has
had wide readership with numerous
international in traditions mr. Coggins
most recent book the next hundred
million America in 2050 was published in
2010 in each of these books and his very
many other publications joel Kotkin has
documented and interpreted and in many
ways successfully predicted some of the
most important events of our time please
join me in welcoming joel Kotkin 30th
Brendan Gill lecturer as he delivers the
talk the American landscape in 2050 Joe
I'm going to start off with a first time
I'm thrilled to be here you know the I
guess they didn't know that they let
Berkeley guys speak at Yale so I'm
rarely rarely but we'll make this
exception um what I'm going to do is I'm
going to go through a lot of material I
changed a lot of things because we now
have the 2010 census so I thought it
would be fun to sort of say what did the
census tell us a lot of the things I'm
going to talk about it probably things
you don't want to hear certainly maybe
some of your professors don't want to
hear some of your future employers
probably don't want to hear but you're
going to hear them anyway so um let me
start off by talking a little bit about
sort of the big picture this Amsterdam
which 18th century Amsterdam is 17th
century Amsterdam's kind of my one of my
great ideals in the book the city um and
of course this wonderful quote from they
call the an inventory of the possible
other words i think cities should be
about places that are transformational
for the people who go there and one of
the things that worries me about cities
today and I've been very involved in
writing about the issue of class and
I'll bring that up several times tonight
is that cities are now increasingly
becoming the the more elite cities are
becoming places that really are not very
good at bringing in and transforming
people the way my grandparents and my
parents were transformed coming from the
shuttle in Russia to to New York City
those kinds of opportunities are rarer
and rarer in our great cities and
they're becoming more and more what you
might call boutique city so we'll get
into a little bit of that whereas let's
say Amsterdam was a place that brought
people from the German countryside the
Dutch countryside people coming from
Spain people coming from Portugal and
recreating themselves and that's really
what I think the magic of a great city
is all about so I want to talk about a
few things one is population dynamics
I'm going to arrive just started a
project on the whole question of
childlessness and in the 21st century on
a global level
so I've been very involved in concerned
with the issue of population dynamics
and how are we designing cities and
places so people can have children
because in we've been sort of school de
particularly on those of us who are
boomers in the fact that we had too many
people but in many parts of the world
the biggest problem is really going to
be aging and and eventually population
implosion which i think is beginning to
take place in this is a big issue
particularly I teach it in Singapore and
it's a very big issue there I want to
talk about something that architects
sometimes ignore what is it that people
want I mean other words it's not what
the architectural critics want but what
people want what works for people one of
the great things of you know one of the
great things about a New England town or
or Amsterdam but 17th century I'm Sam is
that they really did seem to be
something that was accommodating to you
basic human needs talk a little bit
about the future of the middle class
which is obviously a big topic today and
then I'm going to throw out some stuff
on sustainability which is a word that
every time I hear it I want to rush to
the bathroom but um because it is one of
the most overused and most exploited
terms often exploited by people who have
no business talking about it at all okay
here's our as of now we would expect
that by 2050 United States would have
about a hundred million more people the
United States has a is really a
distinction as being the only advanced
industrial country with a rapidly
growing population of of any size
Australia to some extent has this Canada
has it mostly from mostly from
immigration but the other reasons is
religiosity which I know is a dirty word
in most universities but religious
people have kids and secular people
generally speaking or less likely to
have kids and then the question of how
the numbers of kids arm and the fact
that we have land and we have
single-family homes because one thing is
absolutely true is in the modern context
density
drops family formation and drops number
of children people have it's just it's
it's pretty clear and this is by the way
one of the great challenges that we have
in singapore now is obviously singapore
has to be dense how do we build dense
places where people would have children
because their fertility rate is about
half that of the united states um will
the United States hit 400 million this
have been some people say 500 million
sub say 450 now it there is a scenario
which could have us down about 317 that
it would be a cutback in immigration
some of it by policy some of it by the
fact that the birth rates in many of our
major sending countries have dropped
dramatically it's interesting Brazil and
Iran of two countries actually have
lower fertility rates in the United
States now just finished a big project
on this and many of our sending
countries most of East Asia has a very
very low birth rates and so it's
conceived and even Mexico has actually
dropped it down to around two so that
may have an effect and then if we if we
had a planning regime which many
architects would like in which we only
had high density housing near bus stops
arm that would probably depress your
housing as well your population as well
you know some people think that'd be
good some people think the less humans
the better as long as you know we don't
eliminate them um the this this puts us
in a very unique and both advantageous
and also challenging situation the
workforce the United States between 2000
and 2050 supposed to go up about forty
percent you guys are basically in the
very dangerous situation as we boomers
were in the 70s big increase in the
labor force during an extraordinarily
weak economy I think there was a very
clever remark about the the best
solution was to marry rich marry young I
think of it was that your advice okay
yeah okay
I guess I married old and didn't marry a
rich person so I'm obviously quite
stupid China is a very interesting case
started going to China 30 years ago they
are facing particularly their urban
areas on a real population implosion
they will probably see their workforce
begin to decline about 20-30 2040 I
think it may happen faster because of
the fact that so many Chinese are not
having kids and then they have this
inconvenient thing about 35 million more
marriage or age boys and girls now I
live in the san fernando valley which is
the porn capital of the world so we see
this is a great opportunity for us but
nevertheless there would be a problem
but also what's really interesting is to
tremendous slow down in in Europe in
Korea and in Japan where you're going to
see major reductions of the workforce so
we have this weird situation where we
were seeing certain parts of the world
really getting into a situation which
will not be cannibal fiscally the United
States might get through it if we take
this this increase in the labor force
and we actually employ them which is a
question United States and you know I a
friend of mine from Nebraska you know
always hates it when the northeasterners
or Californians say ah countries too
crowded there's no land left and he's
always says well you know what next time
they fly across the country push them
out of the plane in Nebraska this is a
very big country um and what's
interesting is in terms of all land use
the urban part of our land use is
actually quite has not really grown very
much and what's really interesting is
our open spaces increased our forest
land has increased over the last 20 30
is one of the things that's happened for
instance particularly here in New
England but also in other parts of
country marginal farmland has been
abandoned and turned back to forest and
that's probably a very good thing but
anyway we have lots of land and even
though agriculture it takes less space
we actually produce much more food so
there's some reasonably good news
so where are we headed in the United
States I think where are people going um
I don't know if any of you were
basketball fans I mean this may be soon
to be extinct sport but those of us who
grew up in New York are quite aware of
it the where are people going I like
look is will you have to watch people's
feet where are they going you know not
what they you may tell you if you ask
them certain questions in a certain way
you can sort of distort any answer I
don't even know like okay what do they
decide what did they buy and I think
where they're going increasingly is
places where there is going to be jobs
and opportunities many of you I'm sure
would love to go to New York you'd love
to go to Boston you'd love to go maybe
the San Francisco good luck finding a
job and I think that what you're going
to find is that there are limited
opportunities in these places and if you
look at where people are moving they are
moving to places where their job so
there's this theory that people that
jobs will go to where certain people
migrate but actually I think
increasingly people will migrate to
where there are jobs and also where they
can afford to live and that's also a
very big thing I think we will continue
to see some recovery of certain urban
environments arm but suburbia can only
be legislated out of existence that's
the only way you can stop people from
wanting to have a single family house
I'm going to talk about some of the
interesting groups I think are going to
shape America in the next 30-40 years
the aging boomers are the Millennials
who are you um and the immigrants those
are the three groups that are growing
and so to try and understand where these
people going and then I'm going to talk
about where I think we're the built
environment for the future will be the
biggest fact of our times is job
shortage and this is one of the hardest
things for us to get around is about 20
million we're about 20 million jobs
short are this decade even when we get a
little bump up in our employment let's
say 50 or 100 hundred fifty thousand a
month we need about 250
a month just to keep up with the
increase in the labor force so this is
going to become more and more important
as time goes on and as you can see what
we're what we're experiencing is not the
official unemployment rate is kind of
irrelevant the really important rate is
what we call the u6 which is the the
people who are underemployed have
dropped out of the workforce and
nationwide is somewhere around eighteen
percent some people think it's 20 in the
state of California it's well over 20 so
you're talking about a huge part of the
population that really isn't engaged in
the work force and they're going to move
I think to where they can find work
overtime now where did jobs increase in
the last decade now it's very mixed bag
riverside in phoenix and even though
they've lost jobs are way ahead of where
they were in two thousand they just have
more people than they have jobs houston
did pretty well a washington DC your tax
dollars at work I mean Washington DC is
sort of justice gigantic parasite that
is just sucking the life out of
everybody and I mean I I agree that you
should occupy wall street but I think
you should occupy Washington to UM my
Miami has had considerable growth
Seattle of the what you might call the
more preferred urbanus locales has
actually done relatively well but of
course most of that growth is in the
suburbs ER we'll see San Diego Dallas
Atlanta and you'll see where this comes
from soon now the reason I use this is
this is where our stem is science
technology engineering and mathematics
related jobs and as you can see the
growth of you know obviously a North
Dakota Wyoming Nevada small base but
Texas Virginia and where the stem jobs
have been declining include places like
California last the last year one
measurement came out California lost
about 18,000
high tech jobs last year so despite
Facebook and all that hysteria is still
losing jobs interestingly enough the one
place that really had strong stemming
job growth was the state of Michigan
because a lot of Technology people
actually end up working when the auto
industry started to recover to some
extent most of the states on the coasts
had very poultry growth so when people
say to you well yeah there's been job
growth in XYZ and Houston and the royal
crummy jobs that's just not the case
there are a lot of crummy jobs all over
the country and by the way does anyone
know what the largest employment
category of in the private sector in New
York is waiters waiters and waitresses
that's your biggest employment segment
so as somebody said New York is the
place to be if you want to be a waiter
so what is this new demography that
we're seeing emerge one people are
moving to smaller towns and cities for
most of the 20th century the movement
was to bigger and bigger and bigger
cities more mega powelton the more
recent trends are actually quite
different people are moving to smaller
scale cities and many of these cities
are actually much more interesting than
they were a long time but one thing is
you have the internet so if you're
living in Nashville or you're living in
are in Huntsville or you're living in a
whole series of smaller cities you are
plugged in in a way that you were in
your marks talked about the idiocy of
rural life y can tell you there's some
pretty smart farmers living in the
middle of North Dakota and they know as
much about the commodity markets as
anybody trading in Chicago so I think
there's a big trend and about the fact
that decentralization not centralization
is the natural trend the question is
will we arrest it by policy and I think
up until between two thousand eight and
two thousand ten I think it is possible
that the federal government would have
tried to do it I think the political
reality is that there aren't enough
votes in the dense urban areas to
command the anything close to a
political majority
in terms of the Congress if we take a
look at domestic migration now domestic
migrations different from immigration
it's people who are already here moving
to another place people voting with
their feet Phoenix Riverside Atlanta
Dallas used in Seattle is unusual in the
sense that it is a relatively expensive
area that gets people now one of the
things about Seattle is they have
something called an economy and they
have companies like you know Microsoft
in costco in starbucks that are growing
amazon that are growing concerns that
employ lots of people they're very
unusual in that way people have been
leaving a los angeles new york one of
the interesting things about LA which is
my adopted hometown uh our population
growth between 2000-2010 was the least
we've had since the turn of the century
there so you know are brilliant in
quotes mayor villaraigosa said well
we're going to have to accompany people
going to have to densify everything I
said Antonia where are the people there
you have to have people coming in plus a
lot of this density was very expensive
so so what you have is luxury condos now
inhabited by USC students and after a
generation of USC students they won't be
very luxurious what areas of growing
overall in population again Las Vegas a
lot of the problems that some of these
areas have is they grew very fast and
then the economy cratered and so they
have lots of problems but Raleigh Austin
are certainly in much better shape
Charlotte is in between but basically
the population growth continues to go to
the city so you know since your
architecture supposed to be building
something for people who actually need
it and this is probably where you're
going to see the growth some places like
Nashville Denver so they're not you know
you don't have to move to Euston I mean
I happen to like Euston but I'm after ye
also like Los Angeles so but I think
that you there are many cities of
smaller cities that are going to be
pretty attractive to people again I
would look at Nashville
as ones that might be attractive to some
of you the slowest growth again you can
see where the slowest growth is I mean
one of the great things that's happened
there's been this this very very slow
growth out New Orleans by the way is
really an interesting case I'm working
on a project in New Orleans right now
and it is beginning to turn around very
quickly and if I was an architect which
I'm not I would really think about New
Orleans because they're doing they're
building their rebuilding and the the
city is now attracting lots of people
from the both coasts who want to be in
this place with great music great
architecture the best food in the
country and is still cheap so what I
when I go to New Orleans I'm very struck
by the number of really bright young
people go there there's a growing film
industry they're growing video industry
they're one of the it's one of the
places where a lot of the game companies
are looking at very interesting place to
look at in the future next ten years is
New Orleans but you know the end you
have your usual Rust Belt cities that
have done very poorly but it's very
interesting that places like LA and San
Francisco have also grown very slowly
these are the metro areas in some cases
the cities have either had no population
growth or lost population one of the big
things that's driving a lot of this
these demographics are the price of
housing on the multiple that the median
multiple is a ratio we use of how many
years of income would it take the median
income to buy a median price house this
is stuff that I know architects don't
want to talk about but i'll talk about
it so what happens is you begin to get
if you get a certain places that become
very unaffordable um and so people
either leave their or as i just came
back from Australia where they have
incredibly draconian legislation for
place that's got point three percent of
its land urbanized that they now have
like for instance Adelaide is more
expensive than Seattle makes no sense at
all and it's beginning to affect their
economy and that people's mortgage
payments are such a huge percentage of
their income even though their economies
dunno
okay um in the u.s. there were some
fairly reasonably priced places but
generally speaking historically it was
three years income median income for a
for a house for median price house and
in many parts of the US and the UK and
Australia it can be about six seven in
some places eight we are starting to
work in in Singapore we may think it may
now be 20 in Singapore and 11 12 in Hong
Kong so that means that the the
possibility say that what's interesting
is you got to think of it from the point
of view of the next generation of buyers
so very often boomers being arrogant and
self-centered look at the world they say
well you know I bought my house in San
Francisco in 1980 and I did okay yeah
you did really well but how about that
the kid who who came in and made one to
live in San Francisco Kent has no hope
of ever buying a house I had a one of
those road to Damascus moments when i
was on working on a project in st. Louis
at Washington University postdocs you
know the the brightest of the bright in
every city would like to have these
people and I was sort of doing my usual
questioning and I said what are you
doing in st. Louis why would you be in
st. listen but they said to me is I
would like to live in Boston I'd like to
live in San Diego I'd like to live in
New York but I would never be able to
buy a house because for your generation
the choices may be more limited than
they were from my generation frankly I
couldn't afford the house i live in
right now if i had to buy it now and so
what you're seeing is a pushing out
effect in which many younger people are
and as you'll see later immigrants are
being to move to more affordable places
the word affordability and architecture
probably don't match very well but
nevertheless it is a reality of most
people's lives so then we started to
look at where people moving what size of
city are they moving and basically the
sweet spot seems to be somewhere between
way maybe two and a half million and
300,000 you know when I was in Nashville
recently was really interesting is
I just asked him how much was a house
and where could you go you could live 30
minutes from downtown Nashville and live
in the countryside you could also buy an
apartment in the middle of the city for
250 thousand three hundred thousand
dollars in a really nice neighborhood so
this is something that we're beginning
to see where we start studying where are
people moving to and we find
affordability is important but look
Youngstown is affordable too so it's
it's got to be affordable it's got to
have jobs and then you basically start
to figure out what you what your
relative quality of life is so is I
always like to term affordable quality
of life you know people say to me well
when you want to live in New York I said
well you know if Mike Bloomberg gives me
his place I'll move to New York but the
fact that matters I've got two kids in
the dog and the wife and there's no way
I could possibly afford to live in New
York City none zero I mean it would wipe
out everything I've earned in my life to
live in New York City so I'm not going
and as you can see the big metros have
generally lost in domestic migration so
I thought you'd get a kick out of this
one we have a technology now that we use
where we want to find out where are
people going from one place to another
so we wanted to find out because I was
speaking in Raleigh where are people
moving to Raleigh from and of course you
can see by far the biggest source is the
New York metropolitan area northern New
Jersey the Boston area is pretty a
pretty good sender and then and then
somewhat in California if you go to
denver or seattle you'll see the
movement is much more from the west
coast the idea to me as a you know quite
nationalistic Californian by nature of
that people are leaving California
because they can't they really either
can't find a job can't buy a house can't
live where they would want to live is
actually quite shocking and if you look
at the the migration patterns are very
interesting los angeles county was the
only major counting united states that
has less hispanic children now than it
had to deck
go so well we're pretty sure as Hispanic
families are leaving LA but this is the
sort of the new pattern so if you look
at I can show you Raleigh I can show you
Nashville um I could show Denver to some
extent the Denver is not quite as
spectacular neither is Seattle but they
both have the same pattern of the big
coastal regions losing population people
deciding that you know what I really
can't afford San Francisco but Seattle's
not that and so you see a lot of that
kind of movement okay here's the
question where would you choose to live
now this is the national association of
realtors with Smart Growth America and
what we find is that and what's really
interesting historically the number of
people want to live dense urban has been
between ten and twenty percent for about
40 years it's when you ask do you want
to live in a dense urban environment
that's about what you get ten to twenty
percent now look I'm not that's Joe
against I live in the city of Los
Angeles lived in the city in los angeles
since 1975 now some people don't
consider it a city but i do most people
want to live in a suburb closest city
they don't really want to live that far
out they'll also there's about about
eighteen percent who will go for the X
herb and a lot of them say they want to
live rural communities that by the way
is stronger with older people than
younger people and I think part of it is
older people a lot of them were brought
up in rural areas and have a sort of
nostalgia from moving back to the
countryside very interesting but i'll
show you on millennial attitudes much
weaker interest in the countryside now
when they grow up i'll say they may they
may be different but that's what we know
for now so of course we have the
brilliant conventional wisdom which i'm
sure you've been taught this is our
brilliant HUD secretary we've reached
the limits of suburban development
people begin to vote with their feet and
come back to the central cities well i
would say secretary Donovan you have a
look at the numbers that you ever do
have any justification or you just
reading the New York Times and and I was
a columnist a new
time so I mean I have friends there and
I I think they do some great stuff but
part of the mission of the New York
Times is to sell a new york and dense
urbanism because in my opinion if you're
going to live a dense urban life there's
really only one really great city to
live it in the United States that's New
York as you can tell from my accent
that's my hometown now so I said and
this is that this is the census data
fifteen percent of the Metropolitan
growth was in the core cities let's say
the five boroughs of New York the Cook
County so it's actually even larger than
the core itself we usually use a county
um in the decade of the of the 2000s to
our surprise did not expect this
actually suburban share grew now Shaun
Donovan never looked at these numbers
but these are the numbers that we that
we have from the last census then we
said well I thought we'd you'd be
interested in taking a look in New York
since you're sort of on the extreme
outskirts of New York and this is sort
of part of the general story and again I
believe New York City is the most
attractive place to live a dense urban
lifestyle in the United States I'm
actually I think it's you know the only
other city that competes with it
globally and my mind is London but if
you take a look New York is very typical
trajectory uh the suburbs in the 50s
complete domination city lost population
terrible decade of the 70s and by the
way if you're a peak oil theorists I
don't know how people still believe in
that but anyway if they do um that was a
period of high oil prices you can see
what happened there was actually a huge
Exodus in the cities that was probably
the nadir of urbanism with in the 1970s
on I remember going to the city and you
were constantly looking behind whether
somebody was a was catching up on you
because they weren't going to do very
nice things to you then the 80s there
was kind of a beginning of a resurgent
really starts under under Mayor Koch the
the what's really interesting is that
the Reagan boom was very good for New
York City because of the growth of the
financial service industry then
um in the 90s it was very interesting
the New York urban core grew almost as
much as the suburban areas that was
really hadn't seen that in a very long
time and then we can see in 2000-2010 it
reversed back and so see part of the
problem is that academics and media
people live in a universe and that
universe is made up of people like them
and so people in New York and always
know people who move to New York but
they don't tend to know the people who
left plus a lot of the people who left
are like my family they're from
unfashionable parts of Brooklyn and
those people leave and you wouldn't have
noticed them anyway you know the
trustafarian living in Williamsburg I
mean in some cases you're if you knew
some of my family you'd be happy that
they left too so so what is really
happening over time is cities are
becoming less dense in that their urban
cores have less people now Manhattan has
had some population growth not huge but
some uh but if you go to let's say Paris
the population and I can get you these
numbers of yours the population of the
historic Paris is actually dropped from
its highs same thing with London most of
these cities had much denser populations
and of course of the Lower East Side at
one time was the densest place in in the
in the world I remember taking my my now
16 year old daughter to to the tenement
museum in new york city which is if
you're ever there it's worth seeing to
understand how people lived at how
incredibly dense and how incredibly
crowded that was so what what has
happened is and we'll talk about this a
little bit more is that the urban area
the nicer urban areas I'm not
necessarily saying New Haven then nicer
urban areas um why I got to get you
upset somehow the nicer urban areas have
become what i would call boutique cities
and so what you have is instead of a
family of four living in a in a flat you
have two people living in a flat or one
person living in a flight so this drives
down your
your population numbers because the area
is a nicer the more affluent but they
have fewer families and they're much
less dense and as you can see the one
place that's become denser is Los
Angeles and I predict Houston will
become denser over time but starting
from a much lower base so anyway I
thought that would be kind of
interesting them I I thought because of
I know some of you might be interested
in the global perspective Mexico City
most of the growth is on the outskirts
actually I remember going down to the
you know near the edges and no it's it
there's quite a few people living there
and they're just these gigantic malls
and and you see this all over the
developing world these these gigantic
malls on the outskirts of the cities and
as you can see the actual historic or of
Mexico City is actually lost population
Beijing of course big increase in the
population of the region but most of
that growth is has been in the out the
outer rings the actual inner city of
Beijing the inner part the first ring
that's actually had about stagnant
population and I can just see down the
road you know it'll be a little maybe as
China becomes more wealthier if it
doesn't completely fall apart will
they'll probably be a really heavy duty
you know kind of of yuppie kind of
existence and the inner rings of Beijing
but the growth keeps going further and
further out first came to Beijing in
1982 you know there was a second ring a
little bit of a third ring and now
they're talking about a fifth and sixth
ring and what's very interesting is a
lot of the tech business as is true
almost everywhere in the world is in the
outer rings of the city and beyond the
outer rings I have photographs on this
that I've actually published in Forbes
there are now large essentially slums of
migrant workers which on the Chinese
government is probably not happy that I
took pictures of um
so what is the future of metropolitan
space I'm not negative at all about
where the metropolitan what it was in HG
Wells who was probably the most
prescient of all futurists made the
point he said it'll be a bizarre a great
gallery of shops places of concourse and
rendezvous what you see is not new
office buildings in very few new office
buildings but high-end residents
high-end art galleries that kind of
lifestyle and of course what we're
seeing increasingly in in great cities
like new york and paris and london is
the large percentage of the purchases
are foreigners and people with second
and third residences I think in New York
it was one in ten at one point and now
of course Schumer's in the desperate
need to save the New York real estate
market from some possible problems on
Wall Street he's now talking about
giving people residence visas if they'll
buy property I mean I know exactly whose
interest he is working in as he always
is so basically the that I mean it's a
it's a different role it's not that the
city is going to die it's just the city
plays a different role it plays a
demographic role young people it does
plays a different role with very wealthy
people and then their servant classes I
ie the waiters now what about the
population growth groups that would do
such drilling into the population groups
that are that are coming up the
Millennials your generation is the
largest generation American history
although as a percentage of the
population you're much smaller than the
boomers were at that time other words
the boomers had children but they didn't
have as many children as their parents
had and but generally you would talk
about 80 million basically we're talking
about a group born after 1982 or 1983 we
quote you can call the Millennials or
you can call them Echo Boomers equal
Generation Y but that's you so um we
this is research done by magnet and
associates of big survey research
company
they asked Millennials what is your
ideal place to live now it is very
interesting that they are much more than
previous generations of big cities about
seventeen percent now whether that
changes over time it would certainly
change probably for the smaller
percentage but that's a significant
change we were shocked to see suburbs or
so big we and the theory that we have
and I can't prove it but i think is
young people grew up in suburbs and they
may want to live in urban environment
for a while but when they get older they
still think of themselves with a
backyard and you know and and a some
sort of suburban environment and I can
show you I can sort of prove that to you
um interesting things with the
countryside older people much more
attracted to moving out of the
metropolitan areas than younger people
obviously there's jobs are certainly a
factor there but it's interesting that
we were very shocked because you can see
among the older generation suburbs only
did about a third and they got about
forty three percent among the
Millennials then but again thinking
about basketball and watching feet um we
did a really interesting exercise we
took the generation that was 25 to 34 in
two thousand and said where were they in
2010 this is the wonderful thing about
the census it really is what you know
even if Shaun Donovan doesn't pay
attention to it what we found is that
the population as people began to go
into the mid 30s early 40s shifted
dramatically away from the urban core to
suburban locations by a pretty huge
margin and I think that has to do with a
lot of things how can cities attract
more of these people if they fix the
schools if they keep the great
neighborhoods that are I would say
moderate to low density they could
conceivably capture a lot of that pup a
lot more of that population but on the
current circumstances that's not
happening and so what we generally see
is as people get older as they get
serious about their career
years as they start businesses as they
start to get married and have kids they
begin to move to suburban areas now your
generation is a very odd one because you
have no place to go because when you get
out of here you probably have a hard
time getting a job unless you marry you
know because you could always marry a
rich person well maybe not getting the
job that you wanted to get in the place
you wanted to get it okay well since I
don't I don't have any financial stake
in the University of I just say as
generally speaking this is the case so
of your generation or the people that
you're going to serve they're going to
have a hard time getting jump I'm one of
the things we know for a fact is a very
large number of people in their 20s or
moving back with their parents and that
I don't know where that goes long-term
so then we started say okay where are
college graduates going so we said where
is the biggest increase in college
graduates now New Orleans as I was
saying earlier is a really interesting
case study because I do think that that
people do like a lot of people like the
the historic character of New Orleans
and again affordability but then you're
really talking about raleigh austin
Nashville Kansas City Birmingham San
Diego is the only one that you would
think naturally Denver to some extent
Columbus Seattle Portland you can see
you know it's a mixed bag but surprising
number of the college educated are
moving to places that you wouldn't
necessarily think I have big college
educated populations then we saw just
asked okay college graduates where are
they moving and from the same data we
saw that generally speaking they went to
lower density than higher density as a
group again if you're an editor to New
York Times you think everybody lives in
New York because everybody you know
lives in New York it's like that old
Pauline Kael thing she can't believe
that Nixon was reelected because you
didn't know anyone to voted for Nixon
anyone who's worked in New York
publishing as long as i am knows how
amazingly
out of touch New York publishers are
I've had one I remember when my when I
had a change in editors at the times
they said the new editor said all you're
not going to like her I said why he said
well this the only part of the world
that this woman sees a part of New York
that this woman seasons Manhattan and
the only time she ever sees anything
else is when she takes the cab to the
airport to go for a summer vacation in
France it's about the only time so she
got to see you know I guess part of the
Van Wyck Expressway or something now the
other big group is immigrants now what's
really interesting is whereas the
nativists are all worried about too many
immigrants I think longer term we're
going to have a shortage of immigrants
because again the sending countries are
losing population and as our economy
continues to fumble less reason to come
here but immigration has been the thing
that's really driven the demographic
dynamism and I would argue the
entrepreneurial dynamism of the United
States for a long time so where the
immigrants live well in 1980 they were
about 40 pretty even between cities and
suburbs now it's predominantly suburbs
and now many immigrants move immediately
the suburbs that's particularly true in
some of these Sun Belt cities which
never had big immigrant communities so
there was no reason to go into there
wasn't some historic ethnic neighborhood
to go to so like if you look at let's
say for instance Asian and Hispanic
populations particular agent population
in southern cities they're very suburban
eyes because there's no reason for them
to be there's no historic Asian
community for them to be in in many
cases they're building historic Asian
community so some of the most
interesting places in the retail world
are actually being built for immigrants
in the outer rings of cities now the
immigration is still strongest in Miami
la the traditional ones but I take a
look at Dallas and Houston Dallison used
to now get more a higher rate of
immigration than on then chicago and
philadelphia so
something is happening I think part of
it is that there's job opportunities and
I always look at immigrants as Canaries
in the coal mine they're going to go to
where there's opportunity they have less
prejudices about where they're going to
go then we looked at the fastest-growing
foreign populations I mean I was in when
I was driving around though he was
driving around national to little
Kurdistan in Nashville I mean that was
pretty that was pretty interesting and
there was a there was a little you know
somalia and I mean lots lots of these
places like Nashville and Charlotte and
I think that's going to accelerate as
the immigrant network of information
begins to say you know you can get a job
in houston you can get a job in
Nashville you can buy a house whereas if
you come to Los Angeles or New York
you're going to be living in a very
crowded place with much less ability to
ever buy a house and so I think this has
really been an interesting shift and
this is going to be a big driver of
where there's going to be retail
immigrants tend to have more children
they are generally more upwardly mobile
and their purchasing power is growing
trend ously I might class at Chapman on
monday we're going to the the diamond
centering on jamboree road in irvine
california it in the middle of the
recession opened totally least from the
beginning never never empty dr. Althea
shoe who is the president of company she
said they actually were able to have all
the leases signed before they finished
building and if you go there it's just
an amazing place it sort of this pan
Asian kind of setting but then a friend
of mine in used and I gave him the idea
of which I know it's too bad he never
had any money um of taking old malls
that were dying and hispana sizing them
and he he did some called la gran plaza
in outside of Fort Worth Texas and it is
minted money from day one I mean it is
just and it is packed so I and if you
if you see what's going on in these
places where the immigrants are sort of
reinventing even the mall it's it's
pretty interesting and this is my friend
Tim Sisneros I always you know he's a
brunette related to Henry Cisneros
always say Henry smarter younger brother
the his idea of the strip mall the
future and he's actually building stuff
like this this is actually one of his
projects in Houston and so it's really
interesting also if you're aficionado of
ethnic food in most American cities the
good ethnic food is now in the outer
suburbs or or in the suburban areas in
the best Chinese food in North America
is in san gabriel valley which is east
of los angeles about 5 to 10 miles east
we my my youngest daughter goes to
hebrew day school in northridge
california which is really on the outer
edge of the San Fernando Valley and it
is when now where we go for korean food
this korean shopping centers korean
churches because you know the fact the
matter is most immigrants want to live
one of the reasons coming to america is
down in the house that's having space
when my korean translator on one of my
books came over the house and my house
is sort of a falling apart 1930s ranch
house which we hope to be fixing up um
and she still see what the house 2,100
square feet you know nice backyard she
said only the president of Hyundai lives
like this you know so I now feel like
I'm equal to the president of Hyundai I
mean you begin to realize how to other
people what this dream means and you
know when I spend time in Korea or China
or so of course Singapore and I come
home the pleasure I have walking my dog
in my neighborhood which is full you
know you know the little single-family
homes with nice trees it just feels like
you know it feels like you're so
privileged on on a global level and the
other thing that's going to be important
in terms of your businesses and where
you may be thinking of
developing things is that the immigrants
are also becoming a large part of our
entrepreneurial class you can see
between 1996 and 2010 the immigrant
share of new business start-ups went
from about fifteen twenty percent to
close to 40 they've been the one group
that's continued to start businesses
through the recession now the third
group is the boomers or the old
population and you see that population
is going to grow very rapidly so one of
the great urban myths is well when
people get older they're going to want
to move back to the city not I mean
basically everything I've done the
research on I just we've run a lot of
places on a website called new geography
calm most older people do not go by in
the city now some wealthy older people
by pietà tears in urban areas but
statistically speaking there a very
small number many more go elsewhere and
and of course most of them don't go
anywhere I mean most people one of the
great mistakes that the lot of urban
developers made as they they were
convinced that once the the Boomers kids
were finally gone that they would sell
their homes and move into urban places
you know where maybe it was close to
work or maybe they didn't need so much
space it turns out that the vast
majority or what we call retiring in
place and they're staying in their homes
much longer than anyone I mean first of
people living a lot longer and there and
basically they're either moving out to
go to assisted living or the going feet
first um and if you go to almost any
suburban neighborhood that you'll but
you'll see is a lot of older people
people who are been there for 30 40 50
years and they're hanging on their
friends are there the church is there
they'd like the two activities that grow
when you get older a bird watching and
gardening
and you probably aren't going to do that
in the condo and also these people have
lived in suburbs for years and years
sandy rosenblum was a great expert on
this at the University of Arizona she
says look somebody has been living in
suburbia for 40 50 years isn't about to
step over homeless people to go to a
burmese restaurant it's just not I you
know it's just not going to happen now
there is going to be a great opportunity
in the future to maybe some downscaling
smaller suburban homes in these areas my
mother lives in a place called Rockville
Centre New York and it's really a great
area because they have a lot of
single-family homes and families and
then they have young people some of them
commuting the city and then a lot of
older people i was thinking of the
yiddish word but I better not use it um
because somebody might know what I'm
saying so the bottom line is in this
place there is a first of all in terms
of the use of the sort of town centre of
Rockville Centre is that i talked to a
businessman there says we get the old
people for lunch we get the young people
on the in the evenings you know partying
on the weekend and we get the families
on like saturday and sunday and this
guy's business he's just doing great
he's got a pub on park avenue in
rockville centre and i think that that's
going to be a lot of the future that so
the suburbs are not going to stay the
same they're going to become not only
more ethnically diverse but more diverse
by age and there's going to be all sorts
of need for new construction one of the
most innovative places i know is Clovis
California outside of Fresno where they
take the public schools and then in the
evenings turn them and the weekends turn
them into senior centers so you know why
should the public schools be locked up
and you know why shouldn't those be
community resources so I think there's
some very exciting things to participate
in so anyway we're asking the question
okay where did where did the older
people golf 45 to 54 in two thousand ten
years later where were they and
different very different in some senses
from the that other group
yes they they moved away from the core
cities that seemed that was completely
there a few you even look at New York
City the number of people who had been
there that age cohort where were they
ten years later but the big difference
is they are moving to more exurban areas
they're moving to more rural areas in a
way that you almost you don't see with
the other population groups sometimes
from more space for peace and quiet um
the other thing we see and I you know I
have more data but uh is they alight of
them seem to follow where their kids are
other words if the kids go to Raleigh or
Charlotte the parents will go to raleigh
and charlotte so there's a lot of that
following and of course the kids who may
have resisted their parents being there
by but once you have kids you know what
grandparents are really cheap and good
babysitters okay so where are we going
overall and I use the term smart sprawl
I think that you can see this in if you
study the woodlands Valencia you know
her vine I mean you may not like these
places yourself and I I don't live there
myself but these are places where there
are jobs there our town centres there
are there are all different kind of
housing there's some we should be
building I would say a hundred maybe a
thousand new cities in this country in
the next 20 or 30 years and though and
instead of trying to force people to
live away they don't want to live how do
we build how they want to live but in a
more if you want to use that nauseating
term sustainable way um i think is an
emphasis on families is important
village shopping streets um it's very
interesting if you go to let's say they
the downtown of the woodlands it's
actually thriving it's a it's a very
popular place and you see this in little
pockets in sort of la neighborhoods that
are mostly single-family homes like
Sherman Oaks Studio City where you have
these really nice little walking
districts that have popped up really in
the last 20 or 30 years I think the idea
of separating some of these with
open space is also a very good idea so
the idea is how do you solve the problem
of sprawl within the sprawl the other
thing is well it's commonly said well
how about the question of greenhouse gas
emissions but a couple of studies both
of them out of Australia then there's
another one coming out of came out of
Spain it turns out that actually people
in the suburbs don't per capita use much
more energy and actually in some cases
less than the people in the in the urban
areas for reasons having to do with
elevators and other other public space
plus urbanites tend to be big consumers
they go out they go out to restaurants
they buy things that are very expensive
and have been shipped from a great
distance so I you know I think you can
argue this both ways I think the point
is you gotta deal with the issue of you
cannot tell people how to live in a way
in a way that they don't want to live or
that they might want to live if they
could afford it again if I could have
Bloomberg's house I'd moved to Manhattan
but he's not he hasn't offered it and
the other thing is of the idea as well
if we get people into the urban core
that's where their jobs are well that
isn't where their jobs are eighty
percent of the commuting in the United
States is from suburb the suburb only
two cities in America have anything
close to twenty percent of their
employment in their central districts
one is Washington DC which has a very
big employer that we can't get rid of
and New York New York which was built on
a very unique structure most others are
the average is about 9.7 actually
interestingly enough some of the smaller
cities have higher percentages of people
working in the urban core because
they're easy to get to you don't have
the problem of you know again you could
work in downtown Nashville and have a 30
you know a 30-minute commute and be in
the countryside so the whole idea that
somehow you re-engineer everything so
people can go to their jobs in the
central core but the jobs aren't in the
central core the central core is playing
a different role in the 21st century
then it played in the 20th
and in many ways more similar to the
role it may have played even further
back then you know as a kind of
ceremonial center government center
where we're certain wealthy populations
live but not in most cases most of the
job growth is in the suburban areas and
this is particularly true of high
technology and you've ever been the
cupertino it is not exactly an urban
area you go if you go to Austin the high
tech is all up in the they call this the
silicon Hills it's in the areas on the
outskirts of or sit there are occasional
pockets of high tech in urban areas but
the vast majority of it is in the
suburban area and of course Silicon
Valley being a major example north
dallas is another one irvine is another
one so the fact that matter is you're
creating a solution that doesn't meet
the reality so if we take a look at
where employment is this is the dallas
area and again you can see how dispersed
the employment is this is the Kansas
City area probably within this decade
Johnson County Kansas which is right
across from Kansas City will surpass
Kansas City in employment it's been
growing much more rapidly again
dispersion of employment so a lot of the
strategies that are being proposed make
no sense because it it doesn't solve the
problem of how where do people go to
work and of course this is my favorite
City Los Angeles and you can see the
employment centers of Los Angeles or
downtown is about two and a half percent
of the employment in the greater LA area
most of the employment is spread out big
that's a big country that's Orange
County that's out what we call the South
Bay up there in the San Fernando Valley
where I live this is out to the San
Gabriel Valley and what's interesting is
when you look at how long it takes to
get to work the commutes are actually
shorter in places like irvine than they
are in the San
the city now one of the things that's
happened I have a map in Chicago which I
should have loaded on this one is that
one of the problems is that since jobs
are in the suburbs the people who live
in the urban core have an
extraordinarily hard time getting to job
so they take a long time so let's say
you have the gardener's and the maids
who live in what we call pico-union
which is a very dense area near downtown
Los Angeles and for them to get to work
is a it takes a long time to get to west
LA which is where all the rich liberals
live and then you can see the commuter
are very they're also very bad in the
very far out but because a lot of these
areas aren't very many people and by the
way this also comports with another
thing which is the growth of
telecommuting we figure a vine it's
about ten percent of the population
telecommute now my neighborhood has no
rush hour I live a lot I have a weird
neighborhood that's you know a lot of
movie people a lot of gay couples a lot
of Armenians and Orthodox Jews and
Persians you can imagine but extremely
high level of self employment what
entertainment industry people don't
generally go to the studio anymore they
work from home they go to location I've
studied the entertainment industry for
30 years I and basically anybody who
succeeded in the entertainment industry
is has a house generally in the San
Fernando Valley although Valencia is
also a very big center about sixty
percent of the entertainment industry
people live in the valley and that's the
largest entertainment district in the
world so we also say well what about you
know gasoline prices is one of the
typical things that gets regurgitated up
in a Pavlovian way if you look at
gasoline prices went up about forty five
percent the real growth was not in
transit but in working at home the end
of here's another way of looking at it
between 2000-2010 the and of course
driving alone continues to grow not some
in percentage terms but overall so you
had almost 8 million more people driving
alone to work you had about 2 million
more working at home and transit was
about three four hundred thousand that's
if they're huge investments in in in
rail interestingly enough i have another
slide which i guide I can only hit you
with so much data most of the growth was
in buses because buses actually service
the people who need transportation one
of the great outrages has a
old-fashioned social democrat one of the
great outrages is spending a fortune on
rail systems which in many cases have
very few passengers and then they take
the money away from the bus system and
the whole idea is well we'll have the
the rail system and the rail system will
get a few yuppies to go downtown on the
choo choo train meanwhile we take money
away from the bus system with service of
working class and we've had major
lawsuits and fights about this in Los
Angeles I think we have to think about
more more flexible ways of dealing with
transit than on the way we've been
dealing with it and I and the one thing
is a perplexing is the the coin in the
carpooling that doesn't seem to have
worked out very well and I really don't
have the answer for why that is but it
hasn't worked very well I think that may
have to do in part with the fact that
employment is now so sporadic and and
inconsistent and not that many people
work nine to five and not that many
people live near somebody who works in
the same place that may be part of it
now the big change I think down the road
is telecommuting part-time to full-time
this is full-time 34 million now forced
to think 63 million by 2016 I'm a big
fan of telecommuting I've worked at home
for 30 years I like that you're getting
up five in the morning I can deal with
everybody in England and early and then
I can i can make breakfast for my
daughter's kind of strikes me as a good
way to live this whole separation of
life as you live it and work i think is
going to break
and I think your generation is going to
break it down as one of my students one
said why should I spend an hour going
from one computer screen to another I
mean it just doesn't make any sense now
that doesn't mean that you don't
sometimes come into work or you need to
collaborate and there are certain
professions where you have to but
increasingly there are going to be
twenty thirty percent of the jobs are
going to be susceptible to telecommuting
and the big thing about that is on the
architecture site is the decreasing
demand for office space and by the way I
also think is one of the reasons why a
lot of people trying to take office
space and turn it into residential
because the demand for office space just
isn't there nationally I mean if you if
you track GDP growth with office space
the less and less of gdp growth goes to
the office environment you know if you
go over the last 20 30 years I mean I as
a kid growing up in New York and the 60s
I could see the World Trade Center going
up there if you walk down the Avenue of
the Americas it was like like the way
Chinese cities are now huge amounts of
construction you don't see you see
sporadic stuff and a lot of it is
residential or cultural the great thing
about telecommuting is it is probably
the most efficient and quick way of
reducing greenhouse gases or energy
consumption whatever your concern is and
I think that this is one of the things
that I have a hard time with new
urbanist and with some of the greens
because they say you can read the
California has draconian land use
regulations based on reducing greenhouse
gases and if you read the regulations
the word telecommuting does not exist
and get most American cities and most
cities in California more people
telecommute then then then take transit
so why are we not dealing with a very
humane way of dealing with the problems
I also think that this is going to be a
great opportunity in the architecture
world for retrofitting houses to
accommodate people working at home and
what I really like about this is that it
means that you can spend more time near
your neighborhood in your community
I think that that people working at home
like in studio city in the area near
where I live many people work at home
and they go to Ventura Boulevard to you
know go out to lunch and hang out and
also you can / come more involved in
your kids in your kids lives you know in
a very profound in an important way I
mean this what's interesting is
historically the idea of commuting of
spending a huge part of your day going
from A to B is really a relatively
recent phenomena up until the 1890s most
people walk to work or they worked at
home and so I think we're going to see a
movement back to that and that means
that you can do much more in terms of
local communities the other thing I
think is a really interesting trend also
will affect architects is the resurgence
of multi-generational living this
started before the recession but in 1940
about a quarter of all families were
three generations that dropped about
twelve percent in 1980 it's now about
sixteen percent so there's been a
considerable growth in
multi-generational living and I think
now it's probably considerably higher
because of the recession but there is
sort of this phenomena of people staying
with their families longer or moving
back with their families and one of the
nice things about your generation is
when we've when we looked at the survey
data they asked them what the source of
happiness seventy-six percent said their
family the relationship of Millennials
to their parents is so different than
the Boomers to their parents it's a huge
shift so I see the whole question of
family being close to family having
access to family as becoming more
important over time not less and I
always like this quote no matter how
many communes anybody invents the family
always creeps back at the end of the day
fundamentally why do you wake up in the
morning and you know what really always
historically motivates people and I
think should motivate people is taking
care of their family
and whether that's in terms of giving
physical care or or support or you know
putting food on the table I think that's
really the intrinsic part of our
existence and I think that as we move
away from that we're headed towards a
very scary phenomena which is what I'm
now studying which is the fact that so
many people are not having children at
all this is particularly severe in
Europe and East Asia but it's starting
to happen here too and I think down the
road of world without children isn't the
world worth inhabiting in my humble
opinion or not so humble so what matters
most without appealing to families
countries and cities are in theory you
know they really stagnate we have to
look at multi-generational as well as
multi-ethnic and as we think about how
communities are going to evolve and I
think the the regime of some of it has
to do with the regime of planning but we
are creating such high prices in some
places that you get extraordinary
stratification you know New York City is
now the and Manhattan in particular but
New York City is now the most stratified
part of the isolation that was not
historically the case New York was a
very the New York i grew up in had a big
middle class and had a big working class
and people stayed there for a long time
that's becoming harder and harder either
you either you're at the high end you're
a young person who's sojourning or
you're a young person with rich parents
so you can stay longer or you're a bank
robber so you can pay for it or you
leave and that's I think that's really
unfortunate so anyway that's basically
what I'm talking about i would really
like to get your questions i know these
are a lot of ideas that have been thrown
out that probably are not what you
generally studied but i hope it least
stimulate a little thought
there must be a few questions Thank You
Joel for stimulating and challenging us
all some of us think Manhattan is the
only place you're not well and I and I
think if you're going to live a certain
kind of life you know can always move
back to Williamsburg Eduardo in my case
Flatbush I called you oh oh yes here we
go oh okay it's freezing in here I
apologize it's down here it's really and
I wanted to see if you could please
clarify or expand expand on your
definition of family which seems to be
crucial to your argument and how to help
you incorporated into this idea of
family gay rights and gender equality
and gay rights gay rights and gender
equality in suburbia well okay first of
all in terms of my definition of family
I'm a big fan of Stephanie Coontz who's
done some great riding on this um I
think the fam the family we have this
mistaken view that the 1950s is the norm
the 1950s actually the historic
exception most of American history in
particular we had what we want what I
defined in the book as the flexible
family other words uncles and aunts
older brothers playing a big role this
was a big thing for immigrants and also
his people went to the west you know
people some people died along the way if
you read the novels of the 19th century
the role of aunts uncles cousins was
very big now in terms of of of of the
the gender issue one in terms of women
you know women I one of the reasons I'm
a big advocate of home-based business is
that gives usually the woman it can be
the man somebody stays home a good part
of the time I refused to send my kids to
daycare for most of their lives i think
that they should be raised by their
parents not by somebody else hey you're
sure you get help but
you know I think that's very important
for the child and for the child's sense
of well-being and in terms of gays we
have many gay friends and our Hebrew
days was a special so it's really know
you would call it liberal jewish um we
actually we have many gay couples with
children going to the Hebrew school so
you know I I certainly see no problem I
I I don't understand what it is that
makes people so upset and some of the
best parents I know or gay so I you know
I have no problem with it at all and you
know what's really funny is my my kids
don't see any problem with it either
they have friends over and they are
there are two dads and to moms and they
they don't care I think like racial
prejudice prejudice against gay people
will be close to it you know heading
towards extinction over time you take a
look it's a really interesting think of
interracial dating among people 65 and
older 45% object under 25 eleven percent
object that's a massive change when I
sometimes I tell my older daughter i
said when i first went to virginia my
father took me to virginia and i saw
this you know sort of colored only
hotels I mean none of you would remember
that I maybe the incident would remember
now he's too young but I said to my dad
growing up in New York I said what is
this color don't one thing I thought it
was like you know people painted
themselves and they said don't black
people can't go to the same hotels as
white people might when my daughter says
no way and being from the San Fernando
Valley I said yes way this you know the
so these changes i think that in 20
years we're going to play back pat
robertson and those kind of people and
we're just going to think they're as
absurd as george wallace sounds today
it's a question way back in the corner
on the other side he's getting the
workout he gets the big bucks is getting
ready to be a waiter yeah I thought you
laterz are graduates of Yale Drama
School by the well okay all right and
they're on a very strong career path
okay I don't know if your research
covers this but I was curious you
mentioned a migration within the country
and then it's my great migration within
the country and then migration to the
United States but I was curious
migration from the country meaning
people leaving United States what
percentage that is whether that's
significant and where people are going
and whether that's parallel because a
lot of my will you mentioned college
graduates and where they're going and I
feel like as a good number my friends
went to other countries and then stayed
there so I was curious how those numbers
compared to statistically statistically
infant Esmil I mean such a small group
so few Americans migrate now in your
class IE generally very affluent very
well educated highly skilled there'll be
more of that cosmopolitan but the
numbers of Americans who go abroad is
very small now in this recession there
may be some temptations to go to go to
Canada or Australia but actually those
countries are really hard to go for work
very difficult to get a work permit the
worst grilling I've ever had going into
another country and my wife is Canadian
from Montreal is is going into Canada
and God forbid you might make some money
while you're there so I'm always a
tourist I'm visiting family I'm visiting
family I'm you know Australians are
freaked out date when I was there
recently about three weeks ago they were
so freaked out about 300 boat people
they were acting like it was you know
sort of the the you know the you know
the invasion of Spain or something it
was
it was insane so but generally speaking
very few Americans long-term leave to go
someplace else you know this is a very
big economy it's a very big country you
got lots of alternatives and most other
countries with the exception of Canada
and Australia a little bit New Zealand
are very closed off they really they're
not they're not really that welcoming of
people abroad and I know this from my
consulting work in Denmark when we say
that some of the most very virulent
racist comments I've ever heard have
come from people in Denmark you know so
i I don't I don't think there's much
anyway there there are them but by the
way in your in your profession a lot of
and I've had a couple of students who've
gone they're going to China for four or
five years is probably a great idea lots
of action worth worth doing you're never
going to be Chinese you're not going to
live there forget about it
when Adrian it Mike Everett was that a
good New York phrase that you're never
gonna be Chinese forget about it yeah
i'll call it on the environmental front
and not the sustainability front okay
sure um so much of the growth is in the
south and I wondered if you see any
impacts from global warming coming up
and also water shortages which we see in
the southwest and an end in the
southeast and effects such as that well
the south southwest has had water
shortages from day one always been an
arid region I'm not a climatologist I I
just tend to be uncommitted I just I'm
not convinced of one thing or another I
do think that human beings affect the
climate I think one of the biggest
effects not talked about anymore is what
we call urban heat islands like for
instance downtown Phoenix in the summer
is about 10 degrees warmer than the
desert is so this you know the weather
density is the solution I have extreme
downspout arm the in terms of the the
you know the sea rise conceivably a
problem if you work in New Orleans that
you're always aware of that particular
problem but in terms of water let's say
in California which I know very well a
there's so much water up in the Sierras
we just don't tap it and there's a lot
of things we don't do in terms of of
conservation that we could be for
instance there are crops that we grow in
California we probably shouldn't be
growing given the quality of our climate
in our soil we should really be focusing
on very high value-added crops growing
cotton in California is probably not the
smartest idea in history so there are
ways we could be a lot smarter about how
we do things and by the way also in how
we have we build communities I'm always
astounded when people build communities
they don't plant trees how difficult is
that so like in my neighborhood compared
to where my mother-in-law lives further
out um I would say there's about a 10
degree difference in the in the summer
and as somebody who rises bike every day
I
purposely go to the streets with the
biggest canopy trees it's amazing what
trees can do our house we have gigantic
trees all around our house and it really
makes sense now the interesting thing is
also in terms of Southern California is
building two stories is probably not
such a great idea that there was a
reason for the ranch house because
generally you can keep cooler with one
story and and so what I find is that
what I find really hard is particularly
when you go let's say the downtown
Phoenix in the building you know steel
steel and glass towers and downtown
Phoenix talk about Dante's Inferno I
mean I can't think of a more unpleasant
place to be except maybe Minneapolis in
February then than being in in in out in
the desert also my colleague we do a lot
of work with Holly medeiros who's a
landscape architect from the University
of Arizona originally he says there are
many ways we could cool buildings
without using much power and he has
whole case studies of Shiraz and the
building of Shiraz and how they were
able to build and keep them relatively
cool obviously before air conditioning
one of the great tragedies in the part
of the romance sustainability movement
oh well I think he just I think he's
just really smart but anyway but one of
the things that he does talk about is
that in the Middle East they're building
stuff that's inappropriate to that
climate that you've got to think about
what kind of climate you have there's a
reason why ins in sun-drenched Southern
California you built the the the Spanish
and the Mexicans and you know really
borrowing from the Romans and the
Byzantines and all that way they built a
certain kind of building which makes
sense and one of the reasons I hold on
to my 1937 ranch house is my energy
bills are considerably less than those
of the more recent houses that have been
built so I happen to be an extremely
frugal person personally so unlike Dick
Cheney I don't think that i don't i
don't think the same thing wrong with
with that as a ethos I was brought up
that way and
you know whether its global warming or
use of energy or economic it all fits in
together I think what we need to do and
would be a great challenge for all of
you is how can you build communities
where where people can live something
like the way they want to live but in a
more in a less energy intense way and if
if the architects would focus on that I
think that that would be a huge step
forward trying to force people to live
in high-density particularly in the Sun
Belt is really not such a good idea
Keith that's a question is way back in
with you are giving is going to work out
tonight
I think there's some interesting points
made but your tone throws me a little
bit because it that the politics get
into it and I think in a way that
whether from the left or from the right
they actually interfere with a dialogue
about these issues I didn't think I
talked about politics at all well you
didn't but there were remarks that make
clear at least maybe a leaning or straw
men you know the Shaun Donovan thing
well the show and on of the thing is
just plain stupid if it but also when I
think but I think too it seems like we
need to parse things a little more
carefully so central core city and
suburbs we need to find new ways to talk
about you know conditions of living that
don't put us in one of those two poles
the single-family house or the apartment
building or the tenement and the
single-family house as our you know
obviously I know tenements not what
you're saying we're going but you know
that that precludes a certain quality of
life and the one slide I found really
fascinating was I'd really like to know
who did it the shop you showed where
there was like a you know crystal town
on a hill surrounded by feel I begin to
its kind of absurd but in fact to think
that there might be new models of
density that are not high density or
sprawl but you know new forms of living
closer together a ranch house is not the
most ideal house for the climate of
Southern California in fact if you look
at Heather Spanish dwellings they were
close together you have dense tightly
knit streets you let building shade so
my point is there are moments where I'm
like okay this you know there's he's
asking for for design to actually help
us here rather than playing into the old
you know left right city center suburb
if you which doesn't get us anywhere
well first of all I mean but what what I
was trying to make the point was here's
what the census told us here's the
conventional wisdom maybe we ought to
rethink the conventional wisdom in terms
of politics my politics are very hard to
figure out and even I can't figure them
out I mean I'm one of the few people who
does talk radio and NPR so because i
think the it's the ideas and the facts
that man
or you know to me branch houses are you
know relative to two-story you know
little the two-story houses they've been
building further out are much less
energy-intensive and my neighborhood for
instance is actually fit you know
relatively high density but it is mostly
single-family houses now one of the
reasons you have a relatively high
density is a lot of families and we have
a lot of immigrants and so the
immigrants will very likely have very
often the grandparents also live there
arm and and particularly with the
Armenian families the the the the oldest
daughter will will stay there until she
gets married I mean gotta remember i'm
living in a community that is somewhere
between you know fifteen hundred and
twenty one hundred in terms of you know
some of it is way out on the fringes and
a lot of it is very very traditional and
i would say that what you can say that
about my point of view I'm well I
consider myself politically homeless you
know I I like I I think you know
progressivism sort of has lost its way
it's become very detached from what
people actually want and is not
addressing their fundamental problems
and that's my particular opinion I don't
think the other side has a pretty good
has a good answer either I think that
that what I found really interesting I
thought the most inspired community
building was on valencia the victor
growin and the developers of the
woodlands george mitchell who was an
oilman and what they did there and they
did a lot of really interesting things
with natural features natural drainage
and it's called the woodlands because it
really is filled with trees and when
you've got a climate like euston where
it's very hot having a lot of trees is a
good idea so he's done I I think that
there are inspirational site there are
some nice ones in Milton Keynes in
outside of London is pretty good and I
just think that you know we're going to
need to accommodate this population and
I i'm not saying let's go build a bunch
more Lancaster's in moreno valley i'm
not i don't
that's the direction you want to go I
think you've got to think about some
other ways of building new suburbia and
how to refurbish the current suburbia
and i'm not against there being a little
more density in some suburban
communities i think what happens is that
the very often you get a maximalist of
planning regime that says I want a
30-story building where people might
take a two-story a three-story building
but they're not going to take a 30-story
building and I've seen that a lot of
times I think we should calls us to a
halt okay and continue it in a more
informal manner upstairs in the gallery
over some refreshments thank you very
much
you